[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia hoy vamos a hablar
del acceso a la vacuna francia ya
anunció que empezara su plan de
vacunación desde diciembre mientras que
américa latina' esta inyección solo
llegaría en marzo del año 2021 doctor o
buen día cómo puede afectar una eventual
mutación del virus en el hecho de que no
haya un acceso equitativo a la vacuna en
el planeta
raúl van a ser varios retos lo primero
es que no necesitamos solamente iniciar
a vacunar sino que la vacunación sea
masiva segura y accesible a todas las
poblaciones las mutaciones del virus han
sucedido pero lo que se ha documentado
hasta la actualidad es que no impactan
la inmunidad que produce la vacuna es
decir que a pesar que hay mutaciones la
vacuna sigue siendo efectiva incluso con
cepas mutantes es lo que sabemos ahora y
por eso la invitación también es a que
no solamente haya vacunas y nos ponemos
todo ahora de acuerdo con todo estos
cronogramas para cuándo podría estar
vacunado todo el mundo
es muy probable que al finalizar el 2021
y en el primer trimestre en 2022 ya se
compra la inmunización y munir la
inmunización se va a hacer con varios
biológicos es decir con varias vacunas
no es solamente una vacuna y muy pronto
amat en la accesibilidad tal vez a 10 12
vacunas antes de acabar el año y eso va
a permitir que varios países planeen sus
estrategias lo y plan y lo mejor que
podría pasar no nosotros es que durante
un año se logre la inmunización de la
inmensa mayoría del mundo para que
podamos otra vez reactivaremos
normalmente así es doctor pero además
está el factor de que algunas personas
pueden requerir dos dosis oa lo mejor
todos cuánto tomará entonces un regreso
a la normalidad como la veníamos
viviendo antes de la pandemia
lo primero es que hoy la mejor vacuna es
que no nos dé corona
porque no sabemos a qué personalidad
grave o qué personas puede ser
complicación lo segundo la inmunidad se
genera después de la segunda dosis es
que al menos se coloca la vacuna al mes
y probablemente después de la segunda
dosis que empecemos a tener inmunidad y
lo tercero muy importante no es
solamente que yo me vacuné sino que se
vacunen las demás personas para que se
llene de inmunidad que necesitamos entre
necesitamos no solamente la cun
individual sino masificar la vacunación
para que ésta sea efectiva ese va a ser
el gran reto del 2021 otro reto que
tenemos también doctor en américa latina
son las zonas que son impermeables en
nuestra región que va a pasar porque
evidentemente no es fácil el acceso para
vacunar a las personas que viven en
estas en estas en estas zonas
en el cern a zonas que son
infranqueables geográficamente américa
latina tiene poblaciones es en hacer el
reto nosotros pero también si actuamos
en consecuencia área es donde no hay
corona de luz no hay momento porque no
hay tantas aglomeraciones entonces hay
que concentrar la vacunación en
priorizar en grupos de riesgo en grandes
ciudades en donde se hacen
aglomeraciones y consecuentemente ir
desplazando la vacunación hacia las
poblaciones marginal pero todos tenemos
que vacunarnos y muy probablemente
necesitaremos revacunar nos en un futuro
entonces implementar un sistema de
vacunación que sea accesible para todo
el mundo es el reto de cada país y hoy
debemos estar trabajando en eso y ya
planeando para que cuando haya el
biológico o los biológicos que hayan se
implementen para todas las poblaciones
sin discriminación y accesibilidad para
todo doctor también hay estudios que
revelan que los niveles de anticuerpos
inducidos por la vacuna fueron más bajos
que los vistos en las personas que se
habían ya recuperado del cob y 19 qué
significa esto para la lucha contra el
virus
no conocemos los estudios real y en
realidad conocemos las notas de prensa y
lo que dicen es que una de estas vacunas
cuando se utilizó una dosis completa no
dio la inmunidad que a la inmunidad
natural pero cuando se colocó otra
estrategia la dosis y logro por encima y
la memoria natural
realmente estamos ante muy buenos
biológicos con muy buen eficacia el 90%
es algo no éxito porque es algo
extraordinario y por eso la confianza
está las vacunas es mucho más manifiesta
ahora tenemos que hablar de seguridad
eficacia y sobre todo accesibilidad ese
va a ser el gran reto en américa latina
para la así es doctor entonces ya
veremos qué pasa con la vacuna y nuestra
región aquí en américa latina gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
también gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos en esta sección de cinco
minutos con conversamos con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
en una próxima oportunidad
[Música]